bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 78
sport il est 18h30 si vous nous suivez
en direct on passe tout de suite au
titre en image de cette édition nous
allons vous faire découvrir le fot golf
oui oui vous avez bien entendu cette
nouvelle discipline sortie du trou il y
a un an le foot golf pour faire simple
c'est une tenue de golfer vintage un
ballon de FO et un parcours de golf eux
ils s'apprêtent à traverser le Pacifique
à la rame en juin prochain Clément et
Christophe prendront le départ de la
Great Pacific race pour peut-être
établir un nouveau record du monde
rencontre à suivre deux journées et deux
victoires pour les Templiers des
lancours les joueurs de Manu char se
sont imposé ce weekend face au Molos
dannière et confirme leurs ambitions de
titre évidemment comme d'habitude en fin
d'émission tous les résultats du weekend
mais tout d'abord place au foot
golf
je le disais dans les titres cette
nouvelle discipline est sortie du trou
il y a tout juste un an c'est le foot
golf pour planter le décor c'est une
tenue de golfeur vintage un ballon de
football un parcours de golf pour
l'instant pas de d'anomalie et à côté de
ça ce sport arrive dans les Yvelines ce
mercredi au golf de fucherol pour la
première étape de la foot Golf Cup 2014
et pour le découvrir le président de l'
l'association pardon française de foot
golf et sur le plateau du 7 su sport rom
al Preto bonsoir à vous merci d'être là
tout d'abord première question on a
envie de savoir un peu à quoi ça
ressemble quel est le principe du foot
golf bien le foot golf en effet c'est un
savant mélange entre le football et le
golf en gros on joue on va dire au
football sur un parcours de golf avec
les règles du golf c'estàd que voilà
l'objectif étant de taper dans le ballon
d'aller d'un point A jusqu que dans un
point B donc dans un trou et le tout en
un minimum de cût avec le même règle
cogf c'estàd avec des systèmes de part
par 3 par 4 par 5 voilà donc c'est une
discipline très très
ludique que pas mal de joueurs
aujourd'hui ont découvert et et apprécie
est-ce que les trous d'un d'un parcours
de golf classique sont identiques à un
parcours de foot golf où on réduit un
petit peu la la distance alors on réduit
en effet on réduit on essaie je dirais
de d'aménager les parcours aujourd'hui
les parcours existants de golf
en partant notamment des des des boules
rouges qui sont d'habitude dédié au aux
femmes mais ça nous arrive aussi comme
on va le faire là au golf de froll de
tracer en fait un un golf un parcours de
foot golf 18 trous sur 9 trous de golf
puisque c'est vrai que sur des trous de
400 500 m aujourd'hui on les réduit
plutôt à 150 200 250 m maximum pour
pouvoir réaliser des par 4AD des parle 5
mais version foot golf quels sont les
ingrédients indispensables pour
pratiquer ce cette nouvelle discipline
alors les ingrédients les ingrédients
bah c'est vrai qu'il faut alors je sais
pas si vous voulez parler en terme de
tenue ou plutôt de qualité on va
commencer peut-être par la qualité puis
ensuite la ten les les qualités bah
c'est vrai qu'il vaut mieux être bon bon
footballeur que bon golfeur parce que
clairement c'est vrai que les les outils
c'est plutôt c'est plutôt les pieds
c'est le ballon et et je pense qu'en
effet il faut avoir une bonne frappe de
balle mais c'est pas l'essentiel un peu
comme au golf après c'est toute la le
petit jeu la partie précision l'approche
du trou qui est essentiel donc c'est
vrai qu'avoir un un bon un bon coup
d'œil et et bien juger les les lignes
c'est aussi également très important euh
et après en effet comme vous avez dû
tous le le constater c'est vrai que pour
pratiquer le foot golf même si
globalement il y a pas besoin de
d'énormément d'outils comme comme au
golf on a pas besoin d' un sac on peut
voilà juste venir avec son pas besoin de
club on vient avec son ballon par contre
c'est vrai qu'on a mis en place une
tenue vestimentaire un petit peu
particulière l'objectif étant surtout de
se rapprocher je dirais en effet comme
vous l'avez dit de des du du GO golf des
années 30 40 et donc de venir avec en
effet un certain dress code et surtout
de ne pas venir en habit de de
footballeur donc les les crampons sont
proscrits les les shorts les chaussettes
de football également on vient voilà
habiller en plutôt en golfeur si je puis
dire avec un voilà polo bermuda ou
pantalon chaussures de football
stabilisé et puis après on a la petite
touche VO là que je peux montrer donc
c'est le petit le petit beret spécifique
du footall c'est vrai les de les deux
aspects spécifiques ce sont les
chaussettes hautes version jacard et le
et ce petit beret Kepi voilà que que que
comportaient les les premiers foot
golfeerss un un dress code bien précis
vous parliez de la la qualité du joueur
ça veut dire qu'il faut être quand même
footballeur de haut niveau pour être bon
sur le foot golf ou pas alors pour être
bon c'est mieux en effet on a vu
quelques quelques notamment quelques
gardiens de but qui sur les les
forcément sur les premières frappes les
driv on va dire l'équivalent du drive au
foot golf était plutôt voilà avait
plutôt une bonne frappe après sur les
approches benah c'est vrai que peut-être
que les les buteurs sont plus à l'aise
parce que ont l'habitude voilà de de
viser juste euh mais c'est vrai qu'après
ce qui tout l'intérêt du footgolf c'est
que voilà de 7 ans à 77 ans globalement
on peut y jouer on peut prendre du
plaisir et et l'intérêt du foot golf
numéro 1 c'est vraiment de faire
découvrir on va dire les parcours de
golf à à une majorité de Français qui
aujourd'hui ne vont pas dans les golfs
puisque aujourd'hui le le golf c'est
400000 licenciés et aujourd'hui en
dehors de ces 400000 personnes B il y a
voilà il y a il y a des tas de personnes
qui n'ont jamais mis les pieds dans un
golf parce que pas forcément d'intérêt
pour ce sport ou parce que se disant que
voilà c'est un sport trop élitiste pour
eux et donc pourquoi j'iraai dans un
golf le foot golf a cet intérêt c'est de
pouvoir peut-être faire venir des jeunes
on sait que le golf a du mal à attirer
les jeunes donc c'est de faire venir les
jeunes c'est de faire venir des gens qui
voilà qui qui trouvent le sport aussi le
le golf trop trop compliqué trop
technique et le foot goolf voilà c'est
plutôt le côté ludique le côté il y a un
côté famille même si après on peut le
jouer en version compétition ce qui va
être le cas notamment voilà sur ces ces
15 étapes où même si on est là pour
faire découvrir ce sport clairement on
est aussi là pour pour avec un côté un
côté compétition puisquon sait que là
par exemple
le comment mercredi prochain voilà nos
amis hollandais donc puisqu'on a on a
vraiment choisi cette date par rapport
au match amical francehollande le soir
nos amis Hollandais sont clairement
venus pour voilà pour pour gagner la
compétition voilà ça fait déjà 5 ans eux
que qu'il pratiquent ce sport il y a
plus de 20 25000 pratiquants en Hollande
et clairement ils viennent pour pour
pour pratiquer et pour pour gagner cette
compétition par rapport à cette première
étape on sait que dans cette discipline
les ambassadeurs sont des anciens
joueurs de renom on peut citer
évidemment Jean-Pierre Papin Sylvain
wiltorne ça veut dire que c'est un peu
l'activité de retraite idéale pour ces
ces anciens joueurs de football
professionnel non alors je sais pas si
c'est en tout cas l'activité idéale ce
qui ce qui est sûr et ce qui est
agréable c'est que bah c'est un sport en
tout cas que la plupart des des de nos
ambassadeurs tous les joueurs qui sont
venus pratiquer lorsqu'on a fait les
dernières compétitions les dernières
opérations ont trouvé ça extrêmement
agréable la preuve je pense que voilà
une bonne la plupart voir voilà la
majorité d'entre eux vont
revenir mercredi prochain et et en effet
il pr ils prennent du plaisir à la fois
se retrouver entre amis à pratiquer ce
sport qui se rapproche à la fois ben du
voilà de du du football traditionnel
mais version voilà beaucoup moins
stressé beaucoup moins avec beaucoup
moins d'engagement beaucoup moins de
risque de blessure forcément et quand on
quand on est à 40 50 ans en effet c'est
c'est c'est plus agréable et en même
temps on a certains joueurs qui voilà
qui n'ont jamais voulu se mettre au golf
et qui se disent que le foot golf bah
peut leur permettre en effet d'arriver
sur les golfs et on a aussi l'effet
inverse c'est-à-dire des gens comme par
exemple comme Jean-Pierre Papin qui
s'est mis au foot golf qui n'avaent
encore jamais jouer véritablement au
golf et qui voilà depuis un mois un mois
et demi a pris ses premières leçons de
de golf et c'est ce qu'on qu'on explique
au golf c'est que grâce au foot golf on
peut aujourd'hui attirer des gens qui
vont peut-être se mettre au golf
derrière donc on a vraiment un lien qui
peut être assez étroit avec avec le golf
dernière question on sait que ce sport a
été créé et inventé en 2009 du côté des
Pays-Bas arrivé il y a un an je le
disais en France ça commence à arriver
les
licenciés ou ou adhérant je sais que
c'est plus de l'adhésion que vous
avvezon on est en version aujourd'hui
d'association même si l'objectif c'est
de devenir rapidement d'ici 2 3 ans une
une vraie fédération mais aujourd'h on
fonctionne comme une fédération c'est
avec avec des membres avec des adhérents
bah les premiers adhérents tout
simplement sont ceux qui vont venir
jouer la première compétition puisque
c'est vééritablement la première
compétition grand public qui aura lieu
mercredi sur le golf de froll donc on va
aujourd'hui on va dire qu'on compte au
moins le nombre d'inscrits sur cette
compétition donc pas loin de 200
personnes qui se sont inscrites donc qui
sont aujourd'hui membres de la FFG et et
on espè et on peut le pratiquer
concrètement il y a des des golf déjà
qui sont dédiés au foot des parcours de
golf qui sont dédiés au foot golf en
France on vient de on vient de de signer
les premiers les premiers parcours il y
a pas plus de de voilà 10 jours
notamment le le premier qui a signé avec
nous c'est donc le golf de de Brest de
penarbed qui a voilà qui a pris
l'adhésion avec la FFG et d'ici la fin
du mois de mars en tout cas les gens qui
passeront du côté de Brest pourront
aller pratiquer le foot golf voilà
n'importe quel jour de la semaine comme
il pourrait aller jouer au golf très
bien déjà on va pouvoir le découvrir
dans les ivlines dans 2 jours ce
mercredi 5 mars donc pour la première
étape hein je le disais de cette foot
Golf Cup 2014 évidemment vous vous
trouverez un magazine complet de cette
nouvelle discipline dans le prochain 78
sport départ individuel hein ce mercredi
à 9h et en équipe à partir de 13h
exactement merci beaucoup Romuald et à
très bientôt donc sur les parcours pour
essayer de taper dans le ballon merci
beaucoup vous êtes les bienvenus en tout
cas de journées et de victoires pour les
Templiers des long cours je le disais
dans les titres les joueurs d'Emmanuel
Charet se sont imposer ce weekend face
au mollus d'ière et confirme leurs
ambitions de titre Patrick Jacques de
dickmut pour les images
en 2014 les Templiers ferment d'abord la
porte de leur en but ensuite sur leur
série offensive il faut confiance au
jeune chunchelton le nouveau quatterback
américain montre tout son talent
réalisant une impressionnante course
face à la défense adverse deux actions
plus tard il trouve son receveur Anthony
Couvin qui crochette son défenseur avant
de filer au touchd pour une réception de
plus de 45 yards 7-0 ça s vraiment très
bien passé bon il faut dire qu'on a donc
on a 5
si receveurs qui sont très très bons TR
ou qu qui sont les meilleurs du du
championnat de France donc on facilite
un peu l'arrivée du cterback lui il est
bon il fait ce qu'il faut on avait les
receveurs en face voilà ça c'est la
connexion s'est vite passée il est venu
il est arrivé maintenant il y a un mois
et demi donc tout va bien quoi au début
du second quart temp les Templiers
mènent rapidement 14-0 mais leurs
affaires se compliquent brutalement
après l'expulsion d'Antony Couvin pour
un coup de casque sur Alexandre Laruelle
mais les mol ne concrétisent pas le
possession 14-0 à la mi-temps au retour
des vestiaires Shun Shelton impeccable
jusque là va remettre les moloses dans
le match par une perte de balle à
quelques mètres de l' but adverse un
turnover qui offre leur deuxème
touchdown au visiteurs 147 les Moloss ne
par viiendront pas à revenir et verront
leurs espoirs douchés par un dernier
touchdown de Christophe Morin et surtout
cette interception de thba Conchon score
finale 21-7 avec cette deuxème victoire
en autant de journée les Templiers
s'annoncent clairement comme l'une des
équip à battre de ce début de
saison il s'apprête à traverser le
Pacifique à la rame en juin prochain
Clément et Christophe prendront le
départ de la Great Pacific race pour
peut-être établir un nouveau record du
monde nous les avons rencontré il y a
quelques jours dans leur village de
mmont près d'Oudan avec Jonathan villman
et Patrick Jacques dexp Clément et
Christophe bonjour à tous les deux vous
participez en juin prochain à la G
Pacific race c'est une course où vous
allez tenter la traversere de l'océan
Pacifique à la rame entre la Californie
et Hawaï soit environ 3900 km à vol
d'oiseau tout d'abord première question
qu'est-ce qui vous a pris Clément et
bien en fait c'est une longue histoire
Christophe et moi sommes cousins et il y
a à peu près 3 ans on a traversé
l'Europe à vélo entre Paris et
Saint-Pétersbourg pour réaliser un
reportage sur la citoyenneté européenne
et en fait cours de ce voyage on a
rencontré des gens formidables on a vu
des paysages incroyables ça c'est
tellement bien passé qu'on s'est dit que
il fallait qu'on retente l'aventure une
autre aventure dans un autre
environnement et il y a à peu près 2 ans
on a découvert l'existence d'une course
qui s'appelle la GR pic dont vous avez
parlé et on a décidé de se lancer voilà
c'était l'occasion puisque en fait
Christophe et moi on n'est pas marin on
a aucune expérience de la mer et donc on
voulait faire quelque chose dans un
cadre et voilà VO cette course c'était
vraiment l'opportunité de de de se
lancer dans cette aventure l'idée elle
est née parce que vous aviez besoin d'un
d'un autre défi après ce tour à vélo
exactement donc on a fait la traversée
de l'Europe à vélo 4000 km et quand on
est arrivé à Saint-Pétersbourg on s'est
dit c'est super mais au final on l'a
fait c'était largement faisable on
voulait aller plus loin dans la
performance pour repousser un petit peu
nos limites même beaucoup et donc on a
commencé à s'intéresser à la rame
océanique et la rame océanique quand on
rentre dans le monde déjà c'est un petit
monde donc on arrive à rencontrer des
gens et ces personnes là vous expliquent
comment quand on n pas marin on arrive à
se préparer à un projet alors évidemment
le projet en vélo c'était simple on
avait besoin de prendre des vélos de
s'entraîner un petit peu avant et puis
de partir là un projet comme ça ça
demande beaucoup plus de préparation on
s'est bien documenté et derrière bah
aujourd'hui on est on est prêt à partir
pourquoi une traversée à la rame comme
vous le disiez Clément vous n'êtes pas
tous les deux des marins pur sent non
ahis alors on est on est pas des marins
pursant maintenant au contact des marins
on a compris que c'était possible ce qui
est sûr c'est que la traversée à l' rame
c'est quelque chose qui reste unique
dans le monde aujourd'hui il y a 650
personnes qui ont traversé un océan la
rame et l'océan Pacifique donc nous
c'est la course qu'on va faire c'est San
Francisco hawaai pour l'instant il y a
moins de 40 personnes qui l'ont fait
évidemment ce qui nousit arrivé c'était
le côté unique exploit vous partez de de
zéro pour ainsi dire il va falloir
apprendre un peu tout là naviguer ramer
aussi l'aspect physique parce que
j'imagine que la condition physique doit
être parfaite pour partir dans ce genre
de d'expédition non al c'est sûr que
c'est un projet qui est extrêmement
complet que ça soit pour une préparation
en terme de budget pour trouver les
sponsors que ça soit en préparation
physique c'est très difficile de pouvoir
utiliser un bateau comme ça étant donné
qu'on habite en région parisienne par
que le bateau se trouve en région
parisienne c'est compliqué d'aller en
mer régulièrement donc on s'entraîne
tout simplement sur des rameurs
classiques de chambre et et ensuite
c'est beaucoup de course à pied l'idée
c'est en fait d'être en très très bonne
forme et grâce à notre préparation qui
est assez
spécifique on peut on va essayer
d'augmenter nos performances pendant les
qu derniers mois qui nous restent avant
le départ de la course c'est justement
des techniques qui sont assez facile à
apprendre parce que comme vous le disiez
peu de personnes ont tenté ce genre de
traversée c'est que l'exploit est quand
même d'une certaine hauteur non alors
c'est compliqué d'atteindre le bon
niveau physique c'est un un effort qui
est comme un effort for de marathonien
sauf qu'on le répète tous les jours
c'est 10h de RAM par personne par jour
donc ça fait une grosse part du gâteau
qu'il va falloir manger tous les jours
avoir faim pour ça pendant environ une
cinquantaine de jours minimum une
cinquantaine de jours ouais et au niveau
des techniques de la mer en fait c'est
justement ce weekend on rentre d'un
weekend de formation à la survie en
haute mer donc une formation fait avec
des marins qui font la route du r La
Solitaire du Figaro des gars qui ont une
expérience de malade et c'est pas des
techniques qui sont forcément très
compliquées par contre il faut l'avoir
fait une fois pour pas paniquer au
moment où on est à la baille et où il
faut sortir les fuset détresse ben si on
lance la fusette détresse dans le
mauvais sens on se la prend dans le
ventre et puis finalement moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que ça pas été d'une
grande aide et Gérard d'Aboville je
crois que vous l'avez rencontré c'est on
le rappelle c'est le premier homme à
avoir traversé à la rame un océan dans
les années 80 en 1980 cette rencontre
elle a été décisive dans votre projet
alors tout à fait même même bien avant
la rencontre montre en fait Gérard
abauville a été décisif et une grande
source d'inspiration pour nous puisque
c'est le pionnier le pionnier de la rame
océanique et euh tous ces tous ces
bouquins tous ceux qu'il a écrit il en a
écrit notamment deux sur ses traversées
à la rame bah vraiment ça ça nous
inspire et et ça nous donne envie ça
nous a vraiment donné envie de de nous
lancer dans cette aventure dans cette
traversée à la RAM cette course cette
GID Pacific race il y aura à peu près
même sûrement 20 équipages engagés vous
êtes les seuls Français en LCE j'imagine
que vous n'y allez pas seulement pour
participer quand même on va essayer de
de faire une performance non à travers
le Pacifique évidemment évidemment notre
objectif comme on le disait tout à
l'heure on est des marins qui ont plus
d'expérience et du coup notre objectif
notre premier objectif c'est de terminer
la traversée maintenant une fois qu'on
sera parti comme on a un préparateur
sportif qui va être en télé assistance
il va pouvoir nous dire comment gérer
l'effort à partir de là on pourra voir à
quel moment on peut accélérer à quel
moment on va pouvoir dépasser les autres
et puis sur la fin s'il y a moyen de se
positionner et d'arriver en tête on va
pas s'en priver ça c'est sûr pour être
peut-être sur le podium c'est ce qu'on
vous souhaite et la partie cruciale en
fin de compte de votre préparation c'est
dans 2 mois puisque vous allez partir
aux États-Unis vous allez être sur place
et là vous allez pouvoir être un peu
plus en situation grandeur nature
exactement on part un mois avant le
départ de la course à San Francisco pour
pouvoir nous entraîner et puis préparer
le bateau dans les conditions dans les
conditions réelles on va dire voilà donc
ça ça nous permettra bah d'être bien
affuté et bien amariné comme on dit dans
le jargon des des marins pour pouvoir
partir l'esprit sin vous le disiez tout
à l'heure Clément il y a une dimension
historique parce que ce bateau où nous
où nous sommes il a déjà parcouru un
petit peu quelques quelques océans mais
il y a aussi la dimension historique
parce que si vous réussissez l'exploit
de faire cette traversée vous serez le
l'équipage le plus jeune qui aura réussi
cette traversée ça vous trote beaucoup
dans la tête ça
évidemment ce qui va se passer c'est que
quoi qu' se passe enfin quoi qu'il
arrive le jour où on posera le pied à
Hawaï on sera les plus jeunes à l'avoir
fait et c'est ce dont on parlait au
début il y a quelque chose d'unique à
faire une traversée à la rame ça ajoute
encore quelque chose de plus de pouvoir
se dire que bon les autres c'est pas
tous des des vieux schnoc mais en tout
cas ce qui est sûr c'est que si on
arrive à faire ça ce sera ce sera ce
sera un record pour nous et vous serez
aussi les premiers Français à réaliser
cette traversée du Pacifique dans ce
sens exactement il y a eu d'autres
Français qui ont traverser l'océan
Pacifique donc dont Gérard abauville
mais sur cette route là entre entre San
Francisco et Hawa nous serons les
premiers et aussi dans votre projet il y
a quelque chose d'important c'est un
petit aspect écologique je crois oui
alors c'est même plus qu'un petit aspect
écologique on a un réel partenariat qui
est fait avec la surf rider Foundation
Europe la surf rider Foundation c'est
l'association euh qui s'occupe de la
protection des océans c'est une des plus
grosses qui existe au monde ça ça a été
créé à San Francisco et et nous on est
en partenariat avec l'antenne française
et notre objectif c'est de lever 50000 €
pour participer au nettoyage des plages
des déchets plastiques ça c'est 50000 €
ils vont être directement utilisés pour
faire pour une action locale sur le
littoral français et on va inciter les
gens qui nous suivent à faire des dons à
l'association on va essayer aussi de
trouver des entreprises pour nous donner
le ce financement et et donc
l'intégralité de ce finement sera donnée
à la S frider Foundation c'est
complètement indépendant de notre levée
de fond pour notre notre aventure et et
en plus de cette levée de fond pour
cette association on participera à un
programme de recherche puisque comme
Christophe vous l'a dit nous allons
traverser le continent de plastique qui
est le célèbre continent de de plastique
sur l'océan Pacifique et donc nous
essaierons d'observer la pollution en
mer c'est plutôt aussi intéressant pour
les les personnes qui voudraient vous
soutenir dans dans votre traversée en
tout tout cas on vous souhaite d'arriver
jusqu'au bout dans quelques mois le
départ le 7 juin prochain on vous
retrouve là-bas en direct en tout cas on
espère au départ merci beaucoup à tous
les deux merci
merci Ferrari SIM cette semaine les
licenciés du club de football de traap
ont manifesté ce mercredi après-midi
devant la mairie pour crier leur dépit
face à l'indescence de de leurs
infrastructures où il n'y a plus
d'entraînement depuis un mois et demi
pour certains enfants une action suivie
des faits images de Jonathan Vman
le club de football de trappe et la
mairie ent un nouveau match 3 semaines
après la démission du président mapha
larb entre 150 et 250 enants éducateurs
et parents ont cri le colère sous les
fenêtres de l'hôtel de
ville
par pouréc on pe pas y aller la sécité
par jour d'aujourd'hui on brile et le
jour AA
DESP lesigs du club ré la réhabilitation
de le éip et un nouveau terrain
synthétique car à l'heure actuelle
seulement qure terrains seraient
fonctionnels deux au stade Robert gravau
et deux à Gilbert chonsac dont un
réservé exclusivement à la compétition
tout cela pour 900 licenciés et 26
équipes de son côté la mairie avance que
H terrains seraient disponibles sur la
commune dans l'attente d'une éventuelle
signature de convention avec la ville de
La Verrière pour des prês de terrain le
club traapis semble se retrouver dans
l'impasse on considère que sur la V de
trap on peut plus pratiquer
de manière aujourd'hui a des rication
très très Simp qui consist à demander
des lieux accueillants pour les
adhérents du sécurisant pour no
adversaires quand il vienent de weekend
et des outils pour travailler après
cette seconde manifestation et des
demandes d'audience une délégation a
finalement été reçu par le maire
guimalandin le lendemain un entretien
jugé constructif par les footballeurs le
maire aurait visité les installation du
club et aurait ciblé des problématiques
notamment sur le stade Gagarine où le
club demande tion de ce terrain
synthétique verdict dans les prochaines
heures tout d'abord nous prenons la
direction de Cali et la Colombie pour
les mondiaux de cyclisme sur piste et
cet homme bien entrer dans la légende le
nouvelontain François Pervis a décroché
cette semaine trois titres de champion
du monde en kerine sur le kilomètr et
sur la vitesse individuelle il signala
un triplet historique et il dit jamais
personne n'avait réalisé une telle
performance dans un même Championnat du
monde et il a écrasé la concurrence sur
les trois épreuves sur lesquelles il
était aligné notamment en vitesse où le
double record man du monde du 200 m et
du kilom n'a pas perdu une seule manche
du tournoi et pour le paradoxe sur son
compte Twitter François Pervis indique
toujours qu'il est en recherche de
sponsor nul doute qu'il devrait trouver
rapidement preneur en foot féminin pour
le compte de la 15e journée de Division
2 Montini 12e et dernier recevait ce
dimanche au stade de la coudre le 4e à
mien et comme souvent cette saison la
défense inimontaine sera très perméable
en première période les joueuses de
jeanani Grosset encaissent 6 buts en
l'espace de 25 minutes on ne va pas vous
montrer tous les buts à miennois ce
serait trop long juste ces deux
réalisation et en seconde période les
inimontaines sauveront l'honneur par
l'intermédiaire de laurabousiquet peu
après l'heure de jeu sur cette
magnifique frappe lointaine qui lobe la
gardienne que vous allez voir juste
après score final si bu à 1 pour Amien
c'est la 12e défaite de la saison pour
les in montaines qui restent scotché à
cette malheureuse 12e et dernière place
avec 8 points de retard sur le 10e mais
leur entraîneur veut encore croire au
maintien on l'écoute c'est un match où
on attendait beaucoup d'engagement
beaucoup de beaucoup sur ce match là
déjà faire un résultat à la maison c'est
vrai que là ça nous complique la saison
mais bon la saison n'est pas terminée il
nous reste déjà à préparer dans pour 15
jour dijour le déplacement dijour il
faut y croire il faut pas baisser les
bras et je pense que on peut prendre
exemple sur amen l'année dernière où
Moon avait prédit une descente en DH
mais elles sont encore là elles sont 4e
aujourd'hui en basketball féminin on
avait quitté les féminine de l'Entente
le chaîn et Versailles la semaine
dernière sur une victoire pas d'exploit
ce weekend sur le parquet du leader
Franconville lors de la 19e journée
desfites de 12 points 79 à 67 l'avenir
en National se complique pour les
joueuses de Stéphane rouet vous allez le
voir au classement les versaillaises
sont toujours 11e avec 23 points elles
ont cédé une longueur à Renn vainqueur
de Brive et elles sont reléguées à
quatre longueurs surtout de la 9e place
synonyme de maintien à trois journées de
la fin de la saison régulière cela
commence à faire beaucoup c'est la fin
de ce 78 sport merci de l'avoir suivi
n'hésitez pas à le commenter hein sur
les réseaux sociaux et Twitter avec le
hashtag le 78 sport tout attaché
excellente soirée sur TVfil à lundi
prochain